one of the two train drivers is said to
have called a supervisor right after the
accident reporting the crash and asking
what to do by then it was too late the
train had already derailed overturned
carriages and bodies were strewn across
the scene of devastation CCTV footage
shows the moment of impact coming off
the tracks on a curve before it was
about to enter santiago de compostela
station Spaniards have been shaken by
their worst train disaster in 70 years
Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy himself
born in Santiago de Compostela told
reporters at the crash site it was the
saddest day yo quiero tras la Lara in my
own name in the name of the Spanish
government and all Spaniards who feel
with us I would like to express my
sincere condolences to the families and
friends of the victims of whom there are
far too many linnethia then there was a
minute of silence in tribute to the dead
raha has declared three days of mourning
officials have so far ruled out a
terrorist background to the crash the
rail operator says the train had
undergone inspections that day
suggesting it wasn't a technical failure
but a speculation mounts over the cause
official sources at the Ren Faire rail
company say it won't make a statement
until the trains black boxes have been
examined